now the United Kingdom as we've been
discussing it's gonna be taking the
first few tentative steps to easing its
lock down tomorrow and noting a dramatic
of course that we're expecting but other
countries have already gone further
reopening shops and schools and pretty
constant comparisons often made to how
different countries have handled the
pandemic so to discuss the pros and cons
of the different strategies we Jordan I
biotech and ceramic a spokesperson for
the World Health Organization thank you
for being on the program so different
countries are starting to look at easing
the lockdown taking different steps what
do you think are the best strategies
going forward well good going first
what we see that the state of outbreak
is different in different countries so
obviously every country will look into
the face of the outbreak they are in and
will make a proper decision what we have
said from the World Health Organization
is that countries were planning to ease
the restrictions that have been in place
should really follow some guidance and
that's basically to make sure that the
transmission chains can be controlled
that public health system is ready to to
quickly test isolate and trace contacts
of infected people also to be able to
cope with possible surge in a new new
infections we also have to have to make
sure that care compo for home care for
elderly people as your guest was just
saying also being protected because we
know that this is very vulnerable
population that lives in these
establishments there's also there is
also to be to be really looked on on a
workplace and how we can ensure that
some measures are being taken within the
within the
businesses within offices so we try
really to reduce the the number of new
infections and we also obviously need to
have a population being properly
informed and following the instructions
so eventually these restrictions as they
are lifted will obviously help economies
will help Society and it will help
people reconnect with each other what we
really have to be careful because we
know that this virus will stay with us
for some time one of the big differences
between lots of countries is what
they're doing on schools and nurseries
and now we know of course that children
are much less likely to become seriously
ill from coronavirus but what's the
information on whether or not they can
spread it well there is a very limited
information so as you have said that we
know that children are much less
affected by the virus itself but we know
that they can get infected although very
few a number of children will go into
severe phase of the disease when it
comes to a children being spreaders we
don't have a really a lot of information
we don't have information that would
suggest that children play an important
part in spreading the virus whu-oh has
worked with UNICEF and other agencies to
issue guidance to schools to hold them
as well as we were just saying about
workplace that the schools are also
ready and try to minimize the risks and
we're gonna be hearing from Boris
Johnson later today about a roadmap of
for easing the lockdown in the United
Kingdom given the level of infections in
the UK given the our rate do you think
it's important for him to proceed with
caution this is the advice we gave
really to every country is to be very
very cautious when taking these
decisions to ease down the restrictions
because really what we don't want to see
is that there is a second wave and that
we have to go back to the to the
lockdown that will be traumatized I
think for everyone so it's it's
important that this is done you know in
a stage in in a crack
way so we can really see that what is
the effect of people getting back close
to one another so it is really important
that this is being done very very
carefully so we avoid a possibility that
we have to go back into inter situation
between it
there's also seems to be growing
evidence that I want to ask you about
about obesity and people who are
overweight being more likely to have
complications from coronavirus is that
what you're seeing and do you think
there's even perhaps evidence suggesting
that countries with higher death rates
such as the United States such as the
United Kingdom may partly be because
there are more obese people in those
countries well we are still gathering
evidence on many aspects of this virus
area you will you will agree it's really
new virus that it's difficult really to
generate a reliable data in such a short
period of time so we are looking into
all all possible elements but it's true
that a person who has a healthy
lifestyle who has a appropriate
nutrition who is exercising who is not
smoking will have a stronger immune
system so this is the this is a case for
any disease including including the
corona viruses so we in any case
recommend people to try to have a
healthy lifestyle including the healthy
diet when it comes to deaths we have
issued guidance on what deaths should be
attributed as a corona virus but this
may vary vary among countries there are
also different testing policies in
different countries so therefore we have
to really take a carefully these
different death trays that we may seek
and now there's been criticism just
finally that China hasn't been open
enough at the beginning of the outbreak
about what was happening there's been
lots of distrust about the some of the
statistics and the figures that China
has been posting as well but the World
Health Organization is I guess held back
really in criticizing China even though
they haven't allowed your investigators
in there some say that you're a puppet
for China have you been tough enough
well we are member states organization
we serve 194 countries that we treat
them in a same way
but they are big small rich or poor we
work with the data that are provided by
member states we expect all countries to
provide accurate data as much as
possible
because World Health Organization is
operating under international health
regulations and this document is being
agreed by 194 member states so basically
member states themselves countries set
set the rules and we expect them to go
by those rules China has been a basic
new virus obviously at the beginning of
the of the new new outbreak of a new
disease you will be testing to people
who present with symptoms so it would be
difficult to expect that there is a
accurate number and we should really
look across the board because countries
have completely different testing
policies right now and some countries
have been so much overwhelmed by the
number of patients that the reporting
was very difficult so basically what we
were saying about China was that today
they did share genetic sequence of the
virus quickly and that helped to hold
countries to develop the tests and
basically to do the testing they also
did introduce very strong public health
measures that how them gets their
numbers down we trust the figures coming
out of China many say we are on can we
trust them I think we have to look
across the board so so what figures are
really accurate if you if some countries
for example do not test that population
so how can we have really accurate
numbers if some countries have you know
like Italy was dealing in so many cases
inside hospitals how they can generate
really data because the priority is to
save lives so I think we should every
day that we get is is not it is perfect
let's put it that way data is an
information that helps us make best
possible public health a guidance and
this is what are you okay problems of
course I if the data can't be relied on
but thank you very much for that
interview it's much appreciated we're
out and sadly
you